The biggest and best
part of the intangible things
that I was able to take from
the military would have to be
my drive
to continue for success.
My name is Devon Riley.
I'm an Air Force
veteran, having served
eight years in the world's
greatest Air Force.
I am from New Haven,
Connecticut.
I've been able to work
in the Office
of Diversity and Inclusion,
and I've been able to serve
many different affinity groups.
To be a part of Yale's veteran
community feels really good.
It's an opportunity to see
individuals who are leading
the way in different branches,
but as well as different units.
We served and we've done
some of the things
at the highest level
that we possibly could.
I try to live life that way.
You realize
Veterans Day is a day for us.
Do whatever you can to
make sure our community
still thrives, because it can be
a little tough.
Always look out to other
veterans. We got your back.